[Music]
in the previous video we got introduced
to the versatile nature of carbon can
you tell me why it is capable of forming
so many bonds with so many elements
around to know this let's have a look at
the atomic structure of carbon first
does the atom look somewhat like this
yes the electronic configuration of
carbon is 2 4 that means it can either
donate or accept 4 electrons to achieve
stable state however it's not as easy as
it seems this is because donating the 4
electrons will mean that the atom is now
left with only 2 electrons but the
number of protons still remain the same
right that means the atom will gain
positive charge and will still be
unstable
similarly accepting 4 electrons will
also lead to a situation where the
carbon atom becomes negatively charged
does both the situations would lead to
instability of the carbon atom so the
option that carbon adopts is to share
electrons sharing in carbon can take
place up to 4 electrons that means
carbon can share all its valence
electrons with any other atom we know
that such sharing of electrons leads to
a special type of bond formation called
the covalent bond
so to understand carbon chemistry we
need to understand covalent bonds first
how can we define a covalent bond by the
way in simple words it's the bond formed
between atoms by the sharing of
electrons now the next question that
pops up in our mind is how many
electrons need to be shared to form a
covalent bond is it one electron or a
pair or more than a pair can you guess
let me help you with the answer when we
say sharing it means that both the atoms
need to contribute for the bond
formation right it indicates that each
atom will give at least one electron
from its valence shell does that tell us
that a covalent bond will involve
minimum of one pair of electrons
yes a covalent bond needs at least two
electrons or simply one pair of
electrons such a type of covalent bond
where one pair of electrons is shared
between the atoms is called a single
covalent bond it is denoted by drawing a
single line between the two atoms a
simple example that explains this type
is the formation of a chlorine molecule
how do you think this molecule was
formed we know that chlorine has seven
electrons in its outermost shell that
means only one electron is needed by it
to complete the octet
now here's another chlorine atom which
again has seven electrons in its
outermost shell both of them want one
electron each and that is why we find
two chlorine atoms coming together and
forming a bond by sharing one electron
pair now if we look at this orbit
individually it has eight electrons and
this orbit too has eight electrons
stability achieved for the chlorine
molecules this was an example of a
single covalent bond so do all atoms
form covalent bonds by sharing a single
pair of electrons think for a moment
we note that oxygen is in the diatomic
State that means one oxygen atom forms a
bond with other oxygen atom to form a
stable molecule do you know how many
electrons are shared in this bond what
do you notice there are four electrons
shared that means both the oxygen atoms
contribute two electrons each does
giving two pairs of electrons in the
bond formation so is this not an example
of covalent bond well it is but covalent
bond has one pair of electrons being
shared right don't forget it is a
minimum of one pair that's needed for
formation of the covalent bond that
means this case is also an example of a
covalent bond such a covalent bond which
involves two pairs of electrons getting
shared is called a double covalent bond
it is represented by two lines written
between the two atoms
just like this as seen in case of oxygen
now on the similar lines can you give me
an example where more than two pairs of
electrons are shared between the atoms
wait a second
are we trying to say that a triple
covalent bond also exists between the
atoms absolutely and the best example to
study this is the case of nitrogen we
always find a nitrogen molecule written
like this needless to say that the two
nitrogen atoms share a triple covalent
bond that means three pairs of electrons
or simply six electrons are shared
between the atoms this helps both the
atoms attain the stable state now tell
me one thing which type of covalent
interaction does carbon prefer does it
opt for a single or a double or a triple
covalent bond astonishingly carbon has
the ability to form all these types of
covalent bonds with different elements
yes it can't have any of these covalent
interactions with atoms of other
elements or even with other carbon atoms
for that matter in the next video let's
have a look at how exactly carbon forms
bonds
[Music]